>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Good afternoon.
As promised, I'm Patrick Anderson.
I review books for the Post and all
of us at the Post are very proud
to be part of this event and
very grateful to all of you
for being here over the years.
It's a pleasure to introduce our
next speaker, a prolific novelist
who is best known
for his prize-winning tales
of horror, Peter Straub.
Mr. Straub was born in Milwaukee,
the son of a salesman and a nurse.
He was struck by a car when
he was seven and hospitalized
for several months, an experience
that gave him an early understanding
of the random dangers and
perhaps the horrors of this world.
His father wanted him
to become an athlete.
His mother thought he should
be a doctor or minister.
But he found out, he loved books and
decided to be a writer which he did.
Mr. Straub has published
more than 20 novels.
The fifth ghost story
in 1959 brought him national
and international fame.
>> 1979--
>> 1979, I'm sorry.
[ Laughter]
>> I wrote one in '59--
[laughs], in '79.
His other novels include Koko,
Hellfire, Mr. X, his most recent,
A Dark Matter, and two
collaborations with Stephen King,
The Talisman, and The Black House.
There were rumors of an upcoming
third collaboration with Mr. King,
which perhaps, he will
tell us about.
It's a pleasure to present
to you, Peter Straub.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
It's nice to see you all here.
No matter whom you came to see,
it's great to see you [laughs].
Anyhow, it's a great group.
I'm seeing all the very,
very terrific writers.
It's a pleasure just to
look at Martha Grimes.
The instructions we had were--
A, not to read and from
our work that is, no, yes?
We're kind of guided
in that direction.
And we're told really
just to kind of speak
in an informal way about ourselves.
So believe me that is actually what
I absolutely what I intend to do.
But the bit my kind introducer
gave you is from my website,
and I never intended that to
stand as a general introduction
of my life [laughs]
though it is very accurate.
My father did expect me for as long
as possible, he held to the belief
that it was possible
for me to be an athlete.
He looked at me and he saw a
Green Bay Packer, [laughs].
You know, he-always did have a
very rich fantasy life, my father.
My-mother knew that I had
zero interest in football.
All she wanted desperately was
that I would somehow turn
out to be a good person.
There are so many little clues
as though maybe I might
not be absolutely good
but when I married this
wonderful woman I am married to
and I settled then I actually had
a kind of a career for myself.
She was really relieved.
And actually, you know,
I'd gone on through schools
in the nicest most
regular possible fashion.
But there was always this
question, when I was a kid
of what I'll be good for or good at.
I always did really well in school
and I always really,
really loved reading.
And my parents got
really behind that.
My parents read to me
immensely when I was a child.
I remember being on their laps and
then pointing at the comic strips
in the newspaper, the Sunday
comics and going through those.
Reading books to me out loud.
And that must have fit into
the real hunger that I had
to read as a small child.
I remember the immense frustration--
what I did experience as
the immense frustration
of not being able to read.
I remember pointing at street signs
and saying, "What does that say,"
and they would say, the word is
A-U-E-R, and they would say, Auer,
and I would say, "hour" like
you know, an hour on a clock.
You know like our house?
It didn't make any sense.
I did the same with billboards.
So what does that say, you know.
And very kindly and as
sweetly as possible,
they always read these
things to me to a point
where they read the same comic
books to me over and over,
so that I had them memorized.
And then, I pretended to
read these comic books
to other children, to my friends.
And one day, the most
miraculous thing happened to me.
I was about five years old.
I was looking along,
pretending to read,
and I realized that I was reading.
That I was reading the words,
I was speaking the words
that were right in front of me.
And by that time, I saw them so
often that I could recognize them.
So, there I was, you know, launched.
I want it very much.
I couldn't wait to go to school.
Because I thought, surely in school,
it's where they just give you book
after book after book
and you read better
and better books as you go along.
And then you read more and
more interesting stuff.
So I went along and I
went to kindergarten.
And I was really bummed
because in kindergarten,
what they mainly had us do
is take construction paper
and little baby scissors and
cut out things like elephants.
Then, I remember going home and
telling my mother, I just hated it.
There wasn't any point, you know.
I never have to cut out
elephants in my real life.
I didn't like doing it.
I want to read books
so I read them at home.
When I got to first grade,
and I thought, okay now this.
At last, we're going to
have some relief here.
We're going to get
real books and we did.
But the books we got
were Dick and Jane.
Anybody here remember?
Great books weren't they?
Thrilling plots, amazing
style but it killed me--
I mean, I think I've fairly spent
a lot of time being really angry
as a kid but it was
because of stuff like this--
I looked at Dick and Jane which
we were told to read in school
and I opened it up it said--
>> Run, Dick run.
>> Exactly!
Yes! Run, Dick run.
And then, there's see Spot run
and the next page was the
page that really killed me.
There's a picture of Spot, the dog
running and it said, See, see, see.
And I thought, nobody
ever said that.
That's the dumbest, most insulting
thing I've ever seen in my life.
And fortunately I discovered the
school library, and then I was off.
In every school I went to I
ripped through their library
like it was the gateway to
heaven, which of course, it was.
There's a description that
Charles Dickens wrote of himself
in middle life, about his childhood.
And remember, Dickens
had a very unhappy--
I mean because he was
Charles Dickens,
it was a very unhappy childhood.
For someone else, it might
have been a very ordinary,
almost satisfying childhood.
His father did go to
debtors' prison.
But when you go to
a debtors' prison,
the whole family moved in with you.
You know, they ordered meals out.
A lot of conversation,
there wasn't any work to do.
You just languish there until
somebody manages to get enough money
so you pay your debts
and then you got out.
But what killed Dickens was
that, because he knew himself
to be something other than
the perfectly ordinary product
of Victorian London.
What killed him was he had to leave
school or wasn't allowed to go there
and was put to work in a
blacking factory where they made
like shoe polish, Warren's Blacking.
It really hurt him and it really
made him, but in mid life,
he was talking about this era in
his life and he spoke of himself
of getting home from the blacking
factory and reading as if for life,
reading to save his life.
I think, when I read that,
I felt this recognition,
not that I'm comparing myself with
Dickens, but I certainly recognized
that impulse and that mood
and that kind of rapture.
There is no doubt that I read
and learned about the world.
I read to learn about what
adults were actually up to
but I also read to escape.
So, I could go somewhere else,
somewhere where I would be led along
through a series of episodes
and the scenes and the ballrooms
and dining rooms and living rooms,
and on ships and through jungles,
you know, all that sort of things.
It was still not clear.
It's clear I was very good at that
and I was also good at
talking about books.
But what was that good for.
It seemed, really that my only hope
for a successful adult life was
to go to graduate school and
become an English professor
which didn't sound so bad to me.
And when I got to college, I
noticed, I liked English professors.
And I thought they were cool.
They were different
from the science people.
They are different from
the business people.
I guess it just occurred to
me what I really liked was
that it was evident that
they had inner lives.
That inside themselves, they were--
inside those people are different
worlds, very well inhabited,
well upholstered and interesting.
I loved that.
So, I did-- I majored in English.
I went to graduate
school at Columbia.
I got an MA.
Then I ran out of money.
I wanted to get married.
So, I married, thank
God, the right person.
And I taught at my old
boy's school for three years
until we made enough money.
Then we made our big break.
And we moved from Milwaukee
to Ireland
where I was a graduate
student at UCD,
University College
Dublin, a great place.
Ireland itself is a great place.
Dublin was a great place.
This was 1969.
The minute we got off
our crappy student boat,
which was called the MS Aurelia,
the only ship of the Cogedar line.
If you ever signed up
for an ocean crossing
and you see the boat
belongs to the Cogedar line,
I advise you to go look elsewhere.
It was dandy if you're
20, but otherwise not.
Anyhow, we fell into a world that
was-- that didn't exist in Milwaukee
or if it did it was
not accessible to us.
It would've been, it
would certainly--
it would have existed in New York,
but it would not have
been accessible to us.
It was a world composed of
painters and poets and writers
of elite kinds, of
sculptors, this intense hive
of people all working very, very
[inaudible] way at making art.
And so, we're the most
natural thing in the world.
One problem with my childhood
was that, it was implicit in it
that if you called yourself an
artist, you were by virtue of that,
insanely self-deluded and
self-important and ridiculous,
you know, "He calls
himself an artist."
You know, my father
thought that was just
like the worst thing you could do.
Anyhow, here we were with
these people who were just--
who were rooted in
their own talents.
This was extraordinary
helpful to me.
I was publishing.
I was writing a lot of poetry
with which I was obsessed.
And I published a good
deal of poetry in Ireland.
And I worked away with my
thesis, but it wasn't that good,
my thesis, my dissertation.
And when I brought 200 pages of it,
my thesis-- my dissertation adviser,
a wonderful scholar
and a brilliant man,
named Denis Donoghue,
who's still with us.
Denis Donoghue took
about three weeks
and he called me in his office.
And he said, "Mr. Straub, this work
has no connection with the subject
that you said you were
going to write about.
And also, I must say, although
it's very well written,
it's written like a book.
It's not written like
a dissertation.
This won't do.
You have to go back and,"
and oh boy that's it.
Now, fortunately, this
was a-- I mean--
I must have been really arrogant to
think I can convince Denis Donoghue
that my 200 pages about
Anthony Trollope were really
about D.H. Lawrence which
was what I told him I read
about but I couldn't fool him.
So what I did was I took
out from my desk a novel
that I've written in
the previous summer.
I'd written this novel because,
although, I was deeply interested
in poetry, I also-- I always had
and you would understand I could not
really mention this to my parents,
because they would have
taken this as a sign
of self delusion and
self aggrandizement.
I have always really secretly
thought of myself as a novelist.
And it seemed to me that
novels represented a sort
of territory that I half understood.
They represented a kind of
version of home territory for me.
I could not have expressed
this to my parents.
I could barely express it to anybody
because I didn't exactly
know what I meant
but that is very much what I felt.
So, one summer, instead of writing
yet more doomed words
about Anthony Trollope.
I wrote a novel according to
Graham Greene Principle that I read
about in the End of the Affair.
The narrator at the
End of the Affair,
is a novelist named Maurice Bendrix.
Maurice Bendrix says
writing a novel is easy.
You just write 500 words
a day, drip, drip, drip.
And at the end of the
year, you have a novel.
I thought, well, I'm going learn.
I'm going to take Graham
Greene's word and I went off
to the same place where I did
my doomed work on Trollope,
the National Library of Dublin.
And I brought along
bound notebooks that is--
account books as it were
with lined numbered pages.
And I wrote until I figured
I had about 500 words.
And then I counted them to make
sure I had at least 500 words.
If I had 550, I'd say,
that was a good day.
If I was having a really good day I
may write 600 but then, I thought,
no I don't get to count that
extra 100 for tomorrow's work.
It doesn't take very
long to write 500 words.
Anyhow, I did this and I got to the
end of the novel in like six months.
And I didn't know what
to do with it.
So, I typed it up.
And I sorted it away thinking
there might be something
in there and there might not be.
When Denis Donoghue lowered the boom
on me, I asked a friend of mine.
I asked a person I know,
he wasn't even a friend
if I could send the
book to his publisher.
The publisher I like because they
published John Updike, the novelist,
with whom I was at that
time, more or less in love.
And so, I mailed it off.
And they took it.
Thereby, saving my life, resolving
my doubts about my own future.
The funny thing about this book
was it was called Marriages.
Over there at the signing sections,
I must have signed six
copies of this book.
It was published in
1973 in an edition,
in the American edition
of maybe 2000.
At least half of those
went to libraries.
The other half should
have disappeared
but some people, some
people have them.
Some people read them.
One person even told
me, they liked it.
This was a novel which I
was following with my nose
but went to the deepest fog.
I had no idea how really to
do what I most wanted to do.
So this was my system, apart
from the 500 words a day.
I thought because I loved the
work of the poet John Ashbery,
I thought I could write a novel
that would be the equivalent
of an Ashbery poem.
I thought narrative was old
fashioned and old hat and obsolete.
I wanted to write a book of
glittering fragments all lined up.
That would make its effects through
a sort of associational poetry.
I wasn't that good, but what
I did was, I wrote a kind
of conventional imitation
of Fitzgerald, let's say.
A very good model, if you want to
steal from somebody or you want
to imitate somebody, you can't
do better than that style.
It had one exciting part, in
which a guy seated at a cafe table
in the South of France, sees
a man from his hometown,
walking down the main street of
this little town, [inaudible].
And he's riveted because he
knows-- actually that man is dead.
That man was a neighbor of his,
but who was killed in prison
after having shot another
man in their hometown.
So he says to his girlfriend,
I'm sorry, I--
this is very interesting but I have
to-- I have to follow that guide.
The most interesting part of that
book, it had to do with the narrator
of the novel Marriages, following
this man, he knows to be dead,
down a long, long, long spooky
road into the amphitheater alley.
Then into the amphitheater
and into a little blind alley,
into a little room carved out
from a stone on the inside
of the amphitheater where he
doesn't see the man at all.
It's just a piece of paper with
some enigmatic words on it.
Now, I should have known from that,
that my directions in life where,
would be more narrative than I
wanted to be, more about story,
about mystery, about
matters like that.
And before long, they were.
I see-- I have less than
10 minutes now to go,
and if you want any questions,
we have about five--
four or five minutes.
If you have any questions,
I'm here to answer.
If you don't, you don't--
[laughs], but I'll give you time.
[ Silence ]
>> Could you talk about your future
collaboration with Stephen King?
>> Oh, sure.
If I had more time, I would have
spoken endlessly about Stephen King.
He was a fascinating brilliant guy.
Back when we were both largely
unknown, and had published just
like two books, Stephen King was
sent my first supernatural book,
a ghost story called-- a sort
of Henry James type of
a story called Julia.
And he wrote a wonderful
blurb for it.
Different from all the other
blurbs in that he saw--
he actually understood
what I was about.
A year and a half later,
I published another book,
he wrote a two-page
letter to my publisher
that showed absolutely he
understood what I was talking about.
So, I went into a bookstore
in London.
I bought a book by him.
It was called Salem's Lot.
When it was first being published,
I had no idea what it was about.
And it-- it blew me off my chair.
It was so good.
So, I wrote him.
He wrote me, we lived
London at that time.
The King's moved to England.
We got together.
Well Stephen likes-- even I--
we liked each other very much.
The only problem would be this
thing, with Stephen King is
that he talks too much and he
talks so fast and he says so much.
And he has so much energy.
It was a little tiring sometimes.
Anyhow, but a week after week,
we've gotten to know each other.
He said to me, look
we could have some fun
if we write a book together.
Let's do that.
I said, sure!
Let's do it.
I agree. And we looked at
our schedules and we saw
that we couldn't begin to work
for another four years [laughs].
It was because he owed
four books and I owed two.
This is the difference
in our methods.
But anyhow, four years
later, we got together.
We'd-- by that time already worked
out quite a program for our book
and we launched them together
and we finished it together,
a very rare experience
for any novelist.
You know, to work side
by side with another one.
Especially another one who is loved.
It was a great, great experience.
And we continued to be friends.
Yes.
>> 'm actually a very dedicated
horror and mystery novel reader.
Sorry-- the thing is-- I want
to-- I want to know-- oh great--
>> Good.
>> I want a suggestion of what
to read next, because I learned
about you through Stephen
King and Peter Straub--
>> Oh, okay.
You know what.
There's a--
>> Yeah, I know.
>> There's a very good
writer named John Langdon,
who wrote a knockout novel.
It's like a really, really brilliant
literary horror novel called House
of Windows.
>> Actually, I mean
one of your solo--
>> Oh, one of my books?
>> Yeah/
>> Oh.
>> I would read Mystery.
It's not a horror story at all,
but it's got all the feelings.
It's a very complex novel.
It's a novel about a very complex
crime that touches the characters
of the people who are
involved in it.
And it's an odd book but I'm very,
very pleased that I thought I think
I did something different and kind
of new there and I
recommend it very highly.
>> Alright.
I'll try and find it.
>> Okay. Thanks.
>> Hi Peter!
Long time no see.
You didn't talk about your
love affair with jazz however.
>> No I just-- do we have
another hour or another week?
>> Can you talk about the
genesis of your ideas?
I mean, how do you--
how are these born?
>> Mostly, to the extent
that I have ideas.
They begin with a kind of a
lousy little idea that could come
from like a stock pot of any novels.
Oh, somebody is missing and his
parents have to go find him.
That's the-- - I wrote a novel,
the third it was called Koko
and it's one of my best books.
What happens is a long process of
stewing and evolution in which,
but-- when I think about it for
a long time, I eventually think
about all the characters for a good
time and I set off on a little road
that goes somewhere I suppose I
know of, but in fact that I don't.
Almost always, the little road takes
me elsewhere and the story changes.
Whatever is underneath
the story finally comes
up at a certain point
in almost every book.
After I've been working for
about a year, I say to myself,
"That's why I wanted
to write this book."
You know, I recognize some--
something that has been on my mind,
some-- some deep inner matter.
That's one of my two or
three themes, you know,
like I keep returning to
that always surprise me anew.
It's a real evolutionary process.
>> Hi! You are who
I came to see today.
>> Oh, thank you!
>> I've been a fan of
yours for years [applause].
The Talisman, one of my
favorite books of all time.
I've probably read
it 20 or 30 times.
>> Oh, wow, fabulous.
>> I've read it and I try to
figure out what part you wrote,
what part did Stephen King wrote.
And I can't figure it out.
How do you-- how do
you write like that?
>> That-that is very-- there
are some people who can do that.
The only one I know who is
really infallible is Neil Gaiman.
Neil Gaiman once startled
me by proving that he knew
who wrote what in our books.
But Stephen and I in Talisman
especially did a dirty trick
on everybody.
At a certain-- certain points,
we imitated each other's styles.
>> Oh it' not fair [laughs].
>> And that made it fun.
>> Yeah.
>> Also, Steve put on jazz allusions
so to make people think I wrote them
and so, then I wrote in
allusions that kind of rock
and roll I knew he likes.
Because we didn't want people
to know who wrote what.
We didn't want people
to divide the book up.
The only really funny thing that
ever happened was [laughs] one
of those like reviewer sites long
before Amazon wrote that they knew
which part I wrote because the
parts I wrote sucked [laughs].
So he said, so every time I
came to the part that sucked,
I know that Peter wrote
that [laughs].
>> None of that book sucked
it was my favorite book.
Thank you very much.
>> That's about it.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.